all of a sudden Americans are living in
a less secure world they're feeling
economically vulnerable for the reasons
you just heard they're uncertain of
what's going to happen in the very near
future in any crisis like this it's
important that leaders help the public
feel safe secure and confident all of a
sudden those daily briefings from the
president have been helping I think in
that way
but in some parts of the country the
authorities are doing just the opposite
in Los Angeles Cleveland other cities
officials have begun releasing prisoners
early they want to that anyway of course
but now they can say it's to contain the
coronavirus they're not explaining how
exactly that isn't doing it congressman
Diana Presley wants the federal
government to join in this by releasing
its own prisoners watch you know what is
the guidance both for those that are
incarcerated and for for staff and and
that the BLP use their full powers I
think now would be the time to commute
some sentences to exact clemency and to
take care of our most vulnerable 10% of
those that are incarcerated are over the
age of 60 and already have an underlying
condition we should be using
compassionate release uh-huh notice
there's no compassion for the normal
people huddled in their homes sitting
there is thousands of criminals released
onto the streets nobody cares about them
she doesn't that's obvious but there's
more in many cities authorities are
actually ordering police to stop
protecting the public to stop doing
their jobs
in the city of Philadelphia police have
in order to avoid arrests even for
significant crimes drug offenses
prostitution vandalism obviously are
tolerated but now burglary and car theft
get a pass a person could break into
your home in Philadelphia and not be
arrested imagine that instead the police
will this issue a summons for a later
court appearance and send them on their
way with a prayer that they'll show up
in Fort Worth police would no longer
make arrests for theft under $100 or for
vandalism vandalism in a moment when
people really on edge in Los Angeles
County that's a jurisdiction with nine
million people living there the
Sheriff's Department is only arresting
60 people a day in a jurisdiction of
nine million that's down from 300 a day
before coronavirus all of this is
exacerbating obvious
what is a very volatile situation
schools are closed meaning that there
are millions of teenagers with nothing
to do most of them are good kids
obviously but they are teenagers and
some will be troublemakers because
that's what they're like young people so
how will they behave when they realize
they can loot stores steal cars are
trash public places that the police
responding to it what do you think this
is you know what it is it's a recipe for
chaos and people can feel it
that's why across the country gun sales
have surged the first half of the month
it's rational
if the police announce they're not going
to protect you they're not going to do
their jobs because the politicians
controlling them won't allow them and
then they're releasing criminals back
into your neighborhood what does that
mean it means it falls on you to protect
yourself and your family but you knew
that but some in power can't handle that
idea the mayor of Champaign Illinois for
example is claiming emergency powers
that include the right to suspend a gun
sales the mayor of New Orleans is
claiming even more power
she claims if she wants to she can ban
the transport of weapons to effectively
abolishing concealed carry obviously its
tyranny but it's deeper than that so the
government fails to protect you it makes
your life more dangerous and then it
tries to prevent you from protecting
yourself what is that think about that
for a minute
it's really ominous Nepal malliotakis is
a member the New York State Assembly and
ran for New York mayor against Bill
DeBlasio we should one she didn't but
she's here tonight and we're happy about
it Nicole thanks so much for joining us
are you worried about this combination
of factors all of them created by our
leaders that it's going to make our
street stain more dangerous absolutely
it's actually disgraceful that we have
elected officials that are actually
entertaining this during a crisis
emergency situation we should be instead
calming people down we should try to
relieve their anxiety and work with them
to make their lives easier not put them
in a situation where they they are more
scared of what may potentially be
happening I think what we're hearing
from members of the squad and and
members across the country that are
pushing for this is absolutely
unacceptable and the idea here in New
York that we would even consider this
when as you know I've been on your show
multiple times talking about this
dangerous bail law that took effect
January 1st already 90% of the arrested
population is being real
so what's left in Rikers Island are
suspected murderers rapists gang members
heavy drug traffickers and and certainly
that's not what we should be releasing
back onto our street during this
particularly difficult time or ever so
I'm not a paranoid person I assume good
intent among the people I disagree with
you know I think most people kind of
want to make the country better but if
you see a concerted effort to make the
country more dangerous more chaotic what
are you looking at why are they doing
that what's the idea behind this do you
know you know I think in many ways it is
a power grab I think they do want to
cause disruption and I think that's
something that's very disturbing look
I'm I may be running for Congress right
now but I am currently a state
legislator and I could tell you here in
my community we're working together
bipartisan fashion to get things done
whether it be looking to expand beds in
our community for those who are going to
be ill expanding testing making sure
that we're working to give economic
relief to our businesses and to our
residents that should be the focus of
all elected officials across the country
right now not what individuals like the
member that you played earlier is
talking about just to create chaos she's
a disgrace she's a disgrace to Congress
that that person of course it does and
to use a crisis to push your own creepy
little hobbyhorse that will make America
worse and put people's lives in danger
you should be ashamed and I on a pressie
should be ashamed of herself I mean that
well I hope there's something we thanks
so much for joining us tonight
I appreciate it hopefully I hope you go
to Washington to squat in Washington but
right now we're working together to do
it thank you
Thank You Tucker amen